jeudi soir l'audience ouvert c'est le
plus dans ma cour d'assises vous
demanderai de rester positive vous plaît
monsieur en amont de tests
bonjour monsieur le président je suis
partie civile pour le mr à bière et sur
l'affairé ubs à lillebonne journée par
en bas je vais vous demander vos nom
prénom âge profession
d'autres impartiale monsieur monsieur va
me regarder dans la salle ont procédé au
tirage au sort des six jury chargé de
juger
madame jeannette marot monsieur de
brouillon serge azam laurens m contre
éditeurs
on a parlé du procès en dehors de
l'église
le président malouin pas le pauvre merde
mais en tout cas il paraît que c'est une
sacrée c'est pourquoi vous dites ça
quand vous êtes venu à saint-omer vous
saviez que c'est moi qui présidait non
je ne sont pas venus vous vient d'où
c'était aujourd'hui jaune ou rouge
j'ai jamais su ma descente alors cette
écharpe c'est une manière d'éviter tout
effort vestimentaire
allez c'est elle qu'on regarde c'est pas
moi
pas répondu à ma lettre celui-ci pour
moi dès que je te veux que j'aurais fait
je t'aime
je commande que beaucoup
ce décès